okay so invincible is like one of the
best stories ever this story is amazing
it's so cool and here's a funny thing
people have been asking me to do this
story for like months and months and
months and months and I was like no I'm
probably not gonna do invincible because
I really only ever read The Walking Dead
and I was like okay like well-read
invincible like we'll see words to that
like we'll give it a shot like I'm in
the process of moving whatever like I'm
just looking for content to throw into
my channel while I'm gone and I think
okay we'll just we'll try invincible and
we'll see what happens uh this story is
absolutely nuts absolutely love the
story definitely one of my favorites so
the cool thing about this is that the
story actually picks up about four
months before the present-day I mean
well fast forward you know over the over
the course of that four month period but
we initially just pick up with just this
young kid you know this kid named Mark
and he is just an average guy before you
think about this is that this is kind of
like a like a play on the comic trope
right like there's this average kid who
discovers he can do incredible things
like that's the whole that's the whole
gist of this story you know and the idea
is and he's got a pretty mundane life I
mean he's just your your average teenage
can usually keeps his head the books
right like I mean he's really smart he
studies a lot he's got a few friends
here and there you know but he's not by
any means that kid who gets picked on
but he's not the popular kid he's just
the middle-of-the-road guy but a funny
thing about this is that in the middle
of throwing trash away he suddenly
discovers it ends up being thrown like a
mile into the air which tells him that
he has super strength now the other half
of this is that his dad is a
super-powered guy a little bit more
about him here in a second but the whole
funny thing about the situation is this
so like Marc's mom it's just like oh my
god like I'm married to this superhero
guy and my son might be getting powers
it's just common stuff for all the
grandiose all the pomp and circumstance
that she expresses vibart you have her
husband explaining his adventurous day
and being a superhero team as well said
he went to the grocery store and got
some eggs I mean there's no grandiose
moment here and again that's what makes
it kind of cool is because we're used to
like over-the-top superhero stuff right
like Lois Lane's like Superman what did
you do today like well first I thought
Brainiac and then some guys we're trying
to rob a bank and I defeat it and like
we're you know this is over the top over
the top scenario with this is a little
more toned down and it's designed to
kind of poke fun at those things here
and there now it's no secret dad well I
wouldn't say that Robert Kirkman is like
cynical that he is a guy who is just
kind of like okay look some of the
superhero tropes are nonsensical and
this is designed to sort of feed into
that and kind of poke fun of it but it's
all
was on to feed into the nature of comic
books right like comic books by
definition are for the most part in
escape from the world is the chance for
us to sit down and to basically leave
the real world behind and just sort of
enjoy the adventures of some guy with
incredible powers or some chick put
incredible powers and just kind of
follow them on their adventures and
hopefully the stories are compelling
enough to keep us coming back but that's
the goal and so we basically get this
spider-man desk situation where is this
high school kid that realizes that he
has incredible abilities one of which is
the power of flight now to be honest
invulnerability is cool super strikes
cool flight is like the best power
somebody could have to be honest because
I mean imagine where you can do a flight
like I mean here's oh my god I'm late
for work and then you just like take off
you're just gonna fly there's I don't
have to worry about traffic I mean it'd
be amazing to have the power of flight
there's so many cool things you can do I
would have to worry about buying plane
tickets to go to conventions I can just
fly there it'd be awesome just let you
know the bird of the plane oh this
comment explains like it'd be the
coolest thing it'd be one of the coolest
things ever to be able to pull off but
again the other half of this is that
this is a larger world and it's really
kind of what we would expect we would
expect this to have a little bit of a
larger world that this guy mark is not
the only person out there that has
powers the other funny thing about this
is that what he tells his dad look I
think my powers are starting to emerge
his dad takes the most logical road now
the funny thing about this if his dad
has a much bigger role to play within
the confines of the whole invincible
series of comics but his dad basically
takes smart under his wing takes us
under his wing and says luck won you
can't wear that costume and two we got a
hundred skills let's do this we'll be
pitiful so of course you get taken to a
a to a costume guy now again this is the
funny thing about all this is because in
comic books when it comes to superhero
comics when it comes to like costumes
the costumes are an intrinsic part of
the superhero landscape I mean the s on
Superman is more recognizable than the
Christian cross the Batman symbol one of
the most popular symbols ever created
Wonder Woman the flash the spider-man
logo all these things stand the test of
time is just being definitive
recognizable symbols of hallmark heroes
I could walk up to anybody with just a
circle and put Captain America's whole
you know she'll design on it and say
what is this and who does it belong to
they're dishonest Captain America's
shield
I mean it's just one of the things that
people just intrinsically know is they
inherently know it so it makes sense
that we would move the direction of
getting a costume the play just kind of
differs though is the major body which
he gets his costume it's basically
designed for by his hailer
which is
cool I mean it's a guy that makes
costumes for people that's kind of what
he does now it's not unheard of right
like a Marvel Comics spider-man
developed his own costume Superman's
costumes or as clothes but he was
wrapped in when he was sent to earth
Batman made his own costume I mean
that's usually par for the course in
terms of heroes you know getting their
costumes made what do they're made by
somebody else are made by themselves
this is kind of cool because again what
this does is it also leaves him with the
last remaining element which is what his
name is going to be now the other half
of this is how more views himself as a
superhero historically speaking when it
comes to people stepping out of the role
of being a good guy when they develop
powers and they realize they can do
great things for the world
it goes one of two ways either they're
just like yeah I could do amazing things
for the world I've got powers I can make
the world a better place or they're just
like I'm going to make myself rich like
it's usually what happens it's one of
those two things I would make myself
rich to be honest if I had superpowers
I'd be like I'm gonna be a superhero
just as soon as I'm done finding my bank
account like this doesn't kind of thing
that I would end up doing but and this
instance marked falls in line with the
traditional role of a superhero now
again this is the whole legacy of
spider-man Superman to a degree but
spider-man more so than anybody else
most of Superman's stories are really
covered you know at least in terms of
how we think of him most of the stories
that are covered when he's like Superman
right like when he goes through the
whole era of like his teenage life so on
and so forth and now he's like n I am
Superman now there are origin stories
you know Jeff jobs Secret Origins
different things like that to focus on
the life and times of Clark Kent before
he became a superhero but on the whole
most stories about Superman about Batman
Wonder Woman so on and so forth they're
adults that are established and they're
just dealing with villains different
things like that the uniqueness of
Spider Man came in the sense that he was
a teenager he hadn't grown up and so
when he got his powers he did what a
teenager who was taught that with great
power must be must come great
responsibility would do with those
powers and Peter Parker became a good
guy he stood up for the small guy he
didn't allow people to get bullied if he
could keep it from happening he beat the
hell out of Flash Thompson there's a lot
of different things that he did with his
powers and Mork takes very much the same
Road now it's not nearly as grandiose
and not nearly as extensive it's just a
bully picking on a kid and mark just
pushes him into a locker and knocks them
out and that's really about it but the
name for his character comes during a
meeting when the principal's office and
the personal kind of takes us
interesting stance this is one of those
funny situations when it comes to the
idea of how to navigate the waters of
life and how to navigate those charted
waters Davitt things like that the world
the poll is a little more experienced
and a little more wise but a little more
cynical than we would expect for mark
because remember as a teenager in a kid
who's just that developed his powers
marks pretty wide eyed I mean he's green
around the ears and so because of that
he still has this very much you know
young kid high school approach you know
where it's like I can save the world the
beauty of this is that he actually has
the power to do that but with regards to
the principal the principal again was a
little more cynical he's like hey look
then like there's folks that are just
gonna get paid class just the way it is
you know but some folks get picked on
some folks don't you could be the one
that tries to save them but you can't
save everybody so the only thing you
could ever really do is keep your head
in the books give your nose clean and
get out of here go on to a good college
which is pretty sound advice for what it
is it just comes from a little more of a
cynical place from his experience in
what he's seen that's kind of the
knowledge that he's imparting on mark
but what he says is look you are not
invincible and so this is when he gets
his name this is when he dons himself
pretty invincible name and says that's
who I'm going to be now that's what my
character's mantra is going to be about
now at this point we may just kind of
switch over to how all this happened in
the first place so we actually jump to
mark when he was around seven years old
and his father basically told him the
origin of his life now why you would
tell us to a seven-year-old kid who
probably can't even begin to comprehend
it I don't know but he ends up telling
it to his son when he's seven years old
and what we learned is that Mark's
father Omni Man
basically hails from a whole nother
planet called a philtrum I figure this
so I guess they're velch from vil
termites I think it's what they're
called but he hails from a whole nother
planet now this is kind of cool because
remember Kirkman is written for Marvel
you know he's written his own comics
he's written a lot of publications
across the board well he hasn't written
a lot of grand-scale characters like
Silver Surfer Captain America or
anything like that he does have exposure
to all those stories and the guy's been
reading comics you know for quite some
time so what this does is it actually
draws on the on the history in the
origin of the Silver Surfer and that's
kind of cool here because remember the
Silver Surfer with this whole race that
existed they eventually just sort of
become stagnant in the sense of they had
just said well let's explore the Stars
and once they explore everything there
was to explore there was no new mystery
the only new mystery out there was what
happens after you're dead and so some of
them you know a whole bunch of his race
members of his race we're going through
and killing each other and they were
experimenting with drugs and different
things like that in order to just
experience something new and so because
of that his race more or less just kind
of fell into stagnation for time which
ultimately you know coincided with the
arrival of Galactus and his desire to
consume the planet the one rad became a
solar surfer and so on
but with this this race feel very much
in the same way the difference here is
that they gave themself a singular
purpose they said well look if we've
basically done everything there is to
view and if we've seen everything there
is to do and we're godly powerful people
in terms of things that we could do then
let's be like a guiding force for the
universes so the aspect of The Watcher
is invoked where it's like we're going
to basically send these different
individuals around the universe and
we're going to have them monitor other
races and see if we can't have them you
know allow them to progress to where
we're at so we're not really going to
conquer them so much as bring them into
the fold of gaining similarities or
gaining powers or gaining technology in
a manner that's akin to our own so what
they did is they form this sort of
interstellar force there's really more
of an academy than anything else and so
you know students would go through the
training process they would submit
themselves you know they would try to
become viable candidates and if they did
then they would in turn go out into
space now the other half of this which
were these guys to basically create
defense systems around the planets then
we're monitoring because it doesn't do
any good to like say hey look let's help
this planet evolve if like some other
race comes along and destroys the planet
and all the work was for nothing
and so because of that they create this
kind of protective defense around the
different planets that they're
monitoring but Mark's father had
stumbled across earth and the more he
examined the planet from his own studies
on his homeworld the more he came to the
realization is the planet he wanted to
be on now this just makes good sense one
of the things that's constantly hit at
home on when it comes to comic books is
that for whatever reason Earthlings are
intrinsically interesting like we are
unique in the cosmos in a lot of
different ways maybe it's because of the
fact like in Marvel Comics some of the
most powerful beings in the universe
originated on the planet Earth reality
warbirds
you know omega-level telepath
omega-level telekinetics when it comes
to the DC Universe some of the most
powerful and notable beings hail from
the planet Earth
Hal Jordan from the planet Earth you
know when it comes to like Superman he
takes up residence on earth all these
different heroes all these different
characters originate with earth for some
of this is just kind of a byproduct of
the fact that the stories take place on
earth but in the greater Marvel
cosmology you've got a whole universe
and you've got all different kinds of
races and stuff but for whatever reason
earth is just kind of the central point
in which all major powers derived and so
what ends up happening here is once this
origin story has been told once Marx
data basically taken up residence on
earth to become a hero and a savior for
the planet he had met Marx mom he
basically says look at times going to
come when your powers are going to
manifest
when your powers are going to crop up
and when they do you are going to have
to figure out how you're going to live
gonna have to figure out your own role
in on the planet I will guide you but
you're going to have to figure out what
it is that you're about now at this
point with more kind of going out and
flying in the middle of the night and
exploring a different things like that
he comes across the team team now the
team team I do not need to tell you is a
trope on the team at the Teen Titans
that's basically what this is 15 Titans
but it's kind of cool I mean you've got
like like robot which is basically
cyborg and you've got a handful of
others here and there you know II for
example is basically a Starfire but it's
still kind of a cool thing because they
have their own little personalities and
stuff now the big kicker to this is that
really in this opening story what we're
going to be doing here Eve is going to
have the most development
I mean robot will have some but Eva's
gonna have the most development out of
anybody who's here which actually kind
of makes sense because mark recognizes
her he's like I know who you are
don't I and then eventually you know
getting back to school the next day you
know when the team teams like hey look
you know come hang out with us sometime
we'll go on patrol you get you on our
team if you want so on and so forth he
goes back to school and meets Eve and
it's like okay look I knew that was you
like I definitely knew that was you now
the funny thing about this is that
because of the fact that Mark is toying
with the idea of being a teammate what
this also does is it brings it to the
equation a potential love interest now
again all these different hallmarks of
the superhero thing are being hit on
here one of the reasons why I'm really
pointing these out is because it's very
easy to look at like indie superhero
comics and say well they're independent
so like they're designed to break away
from the status quo there's on to be
totally unique and totally different and
in a lot of ways that's true
you'll find a lot more interesting and a
lot more quirky stories and indie
publications than you will in like the
you know the big three and Marvel DC
value comics so because of that where
you breed image comics and you would get
spawned who's like an antihero and that
kills people you know he didn't really
go through like the traditional hero's
journey so to speak with regards to
stories like this you end up finding
that because this story was designed to
be more relatable for the character of
Spawn because this is an actual kid who
just develops powers one day so again
it's really kind of a cool scenario just
because of the fact that working
alongside the team team they're able to
take out you know a couple guys here and
there nothing too major but again it's
basically demonstrating the fact that he
would make a legitimate asset to the
team now while all this is going on we
pick up in Twin Pines mall only to find
out that a kid wakes up with a bomb
attached to his chest
probably detonating and killing you know
however many people work
in the explosion so what this does is it
creates this sort of dire circumstance
the need for something to be done but
also creates this little bit of a point
of tension the other half of this is
that where mark keeps talking to Eve
just because of the fact that she's like
his only connection to the superhero
community outside of his dad you know
Megaforce and you know the global
Guardians whatever is they call
themselves the wrong signals are being
sent by mark the wrong signals are being
put off mark is putting off the signals
of hey like you're a superhero I'm a
superhero let's go do super you know
let's let's bump super uglies uh her
responses look like she's with under guy
she's dating Rex and this is kind of
funny because the two of them kind of
work as a team but marks in this weird
situation like he's kind of being
friendzone for the most part but what
happens when you're being friendzone by
a chick that you kind of have to talk to
now Mia is kind of a weird scenario but
the fact remains here everybody seems to
comment on this like hey look like you
know she's dating Rex right it's just
kind of one of those funny little
moments because at the end of the day
the two of them do agree to work
together they do agree for Mark to be a
little more involved regard to the team
but it's also more kind of saying hey
look I realize you're dating Rex I'm not
really in that I mean we know he's lying
like we know he's just like we all split
I'm making my move it's exactly what's
gonna happen but still you know it's
kind of a cool scenario because we get
this really interesting interaction
between Mark and his dad right like
they're just kind of flying around you
know it's bad like hey look let's just
sort of go out on patrol let's just go
team up in the midst of their little
flying sessions you know as - it's kind
of like whisking off and saving a city
or you know stopping a major incident or
something along those lines but it's
kind of cool because again this is on to
be a little funny this was on to sort of
poke fun at things but it's also just
this really cool moment between like a
superhero dad and his son and so again
you know from this point we basically
pick up with the idea of a you know a
major conflict that's going on and
actually what is up happening as Mark
fights alongside as dad against some
alien invaders now things go pretty
smoothly I mean it's exactly as we would
expect you know a father-and-son
superhero team just sort of wrecking the
bad guys but in the middle of all this
and once the conflict is officially over
his dad immediately picks up on one of
the missing kids it's been led to a mall
now we're going to find out more about
this you know we'll learn what the
conclusion to this mystery is and it's
actually really kind of cool but with
regards to all this one of the things
that we see is it as dad is a little
more brutal than we would expect in the
sense that one is when this kid shows up
as dad has super speed super strength
different abilities so on and so forth
but when he arrives on the scene
this
bomb is at three seconds his dad
describes a kid at the Rossum I mean he
asked me now quickly tell me who did
this to you but the kid doesn't have
time to answer and his dad just throws
him into the sky and the kid blows up
this is one of the things it's kind of
interesting because it begs the question
could his dad have potentially saved
this kid you know could even like grab
the bomb off of him with the bomb
detonated I mean really with three
seconds - this may not have been enough
time to ask that question to do enough
to figure out what's going on as soon as
dad did the only thing you could do and
just threw the kid into the sky so he
would explode some nobody else would be
killed but in the midst of all this one
of the members of the previous aliens
that were fighting grabs marks dad and
just kind of takes off and that's really
about it and so again what this does is
it allows the story to organically shift
away from you know mark and his
involvement with his father just solely
on mark and that's one of the cool
things about this is because again it's
an organic shift it's an organic
breakaway and so of course with mark
talking to his mom this idea that you
know as mom's trying to cope with the
fact that her husband's basically
missing the idea that Eve and Mark are
basically working together keeping their
eyes on things around them seeing if
they see anything suspicious this is
designed to do two things the first is
designed basically again took the idea
of a potential love interest but the
second is with the whole idea of like
their teacher kind of lecturing
everybody and sort of talking about
things that are going on and so on and
so forth with the whole discussion of
them looking around and seeing they can
spot anything they don't see anything at
all as it was designed to really hit it
like in experience because somebody
there is the one that's committing all
those crimes and so that's one of the
crazy things is because they don't know
enough to know what to look for their
teenage kids that have no real major
big-time experience as superheroes they
do what they can but at the end of the
day they're not Batman you know they're
not these super genius kids that know
everything and know how to pick up on
all these subtle clues and know how to
solve every single crime they come
across and that's one of the benefits of
this is because it's literally a story
where you grow as the character grows he
becomes more intelligent you grow as a
person this is one of these cool
scenarios but ultimately we end up
having a robot you know who's in the
midst of a conflict who is basically
Camille cross-referencing information
with regards to you know all the people
who work at the school all the jobs they
had before what experiences they have so
on and so forth and inevitably leads
them to the idea that the physics
teacher mister hale's or I guess David
Hiles is the one committing all these
crimes just because of the fact that he
was a weapons engineer for a company
called global tech before he became a
teacher so of course this leads Eve and
mark over to investigate David files
which of course he promptly admits to
what it
that he's done now when it comes to
scenarios like this these only ever
unfold one way you know when it comes to
like the superhero showing up on the
doorstep of the supervillain and saying
hey look we don't know for sure that
you're the one that did it but we think
you did he's like yeah I'm the one that
did it
I'm the one that committed that crime
the guy's not going to go out without a
fight like something's going to happen
somebody's going to walk in is going to
be booby traps and the superheroes are
going to be killed something nefarious
is going to take place with the
character of David he admits to
everything that he's done he basically
says look there's a fourth missing
student that nobody knows about this kid
named Derek nobody knows that he's gone
of course you have mark that tries to
you know save him but David Hiles
immediately turns around and says and
now I'm going to kill you all because
I've got a bomb on my chest now the
other half of this is David Hales
motivation is rooted in the fact that
his son was basically bullied and ended
up committing suicide because of his
experience but he's basically kind of
taking revenge on all the popular kids
now again this is designed to basically
kind of hit home at the idea of people
who have been put down people have been
picked on I mean not everybody takes the
same road that his son did but in some
former fashion like we've all been
picked on right like whether it's some
kid sitting behind a computer trolling
people because he has nothing to do or
whether it's because it's a person who's
going around in real life giving people
a hard time because he doesn't have
anything to do whatever the case may be
everybody's been in a situation where
they've been picked on where they've
been made to feel less about themselves
now some people get their revenge
some people get their revenge by
embarrassing than people who are picking
on them some people take a more
nefarious approach but for the character
of David Hiles
he's like look my son died because of
these kids they pushed him to that point
so I'm literally just going to eliminate
all of it I'm going to kill off every
last one of them now the other half of
this is that because of the fact that
his son committed suicide that son died
he basically ended up leading to a
divorce that leading to him losing his
job you know his entire life fell apart
and so we sort of just had this mental
breakdown right he's basically just kind
of lost his mind and he's in a position
where he's just going to attack all the
different kids that he sees and killed
him off in some vain effort to get his
own revenge and of course this leads to
mark basically grabbing this guy and
whisking him away and calling it a day
and that's really about it but one of
the other funny moments too is when Mark
gets back he gets back home he asked
look his dad back yet and she's you know
as long as like no he's not here yet and
so mark goes upstairs gets you know
shower and everything and his dad just
kind of walks in and says I need to
shave and his you know is wife you know
Mark's mom I just gotta like well that's
nice and they just kind of talk about
their days again it's just like none of
this is spectacular
to the family it's kind of new to mark
in a lot of different ways but it's that
but yeah like I was thinking about this
alien and I was put like in an
enslavement camp I lost my powers but I
managed to find a way to regain them and
then I let it rebellion and the
scientists that I freed sent me back
this great big huge grandiose of it
right you know it measures like this
great big huge thing and it's just like
yeah I mean that's cool you know that's
that's that's nice
you know all in a day's work so again
it's kind of this really fun little
story it's just this really fun little
thing I enjoyed it I thought it was
really really cool but if you guys are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys with the sub button to become
part of the Rob forth if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
I am
and Mickelson
[Music]